[Musique]
et vous êtes à l'écoute pour brasser
c'est fou quand il s'agit de ce n'était pas moi, j'étais
en train d'écrire l'
album hachan et
j'avais regardé une comédie spéciale d'Eddie
Murphy intitulée Raw
and in the in  la comédie spéciale il y a
un
il y a un sketch où il dit qu'il s'est fait
prendre et la femme entre et il
dit que ce n'était pas moi
et elle est comme mais je t'ai vu sur le
comptoir ce n'était pas moi mais
je ne l'étais pas je t'ai eu  à la caméra, ce n'était pas
moi
tu sais je veux dire et il disait oh elle l'a quand
même repris tu sais et c'est comme
ça les mecs et c'était tout un
sketch c'était vraiment drôle alors j'ai pensé que j'avais
dit mec c'est tellement drôle c'est un
chanson
dans un sens parce que c'est tellement relatable
et chaque fois que j'écris des chansons, j'essaie de les
écrire là où elles se rapportent à
la vie des gens en général vous savez et le truc
à ce sujet n'était pas moi c'est soit vous
frappez vous connaissez quelqu'un qui frappe  ou
vous souhaitez que vous le
frappiez, c'est très lié à la vie des gens
et donc je me suis assis avec euh dans mon  ma petite
maison de ville ici à kingston
avec un de mes amis du nom de
rickrock et nous avons juste commencé à
trouver la mélodie
, puis les paroles de bonnie sont arrivées
et elle m'a surpris en train de ramper
avec la fille d'à côté et nous
a écrit la chanson
nous avons eu beaucoup de rires parce que
nous venions avec ceux-ci elle m'a attrapé sur
le comptoir vous savez
nous disions comme ouais euh elle
espionnait elle espionnait dans un arbre nous
faisions tous ces autres scénarios vous
savez et de  bien sûr, nous l'avons envoyé
m'a attrapé hors du comptoir
quelqu'un frappant sur le canapé il m'a rencontré
sous la douche vous savez je veux dire nous avons
fini par
y aller mais il y avait tout cela auquel
nous pensions donc en dehors de la boîte
des fous oh ouais henry a  elle se
balançant du lustre,
c'est une sorte de truc fou et c'est
devenu juste ça,
vous savez, nous sommes comme d'accord les gars, vous savez que
nous devons vraiment faire en sorte que
cela soit diffusé, donc nous devons écrire du
contenu pour adultes sans être explicite
et nous juste  pensée  c'était je pensais que c'était
vraiment drôle, je pensais que c'était un tel succès
que quand je l'ai apporté dans ma
maison de disques, ils ne pouvaient pas le comprendre
et donc c'est tellement à un point que mon
manager ne voulait pas que ça continue sur le
album il pensait que c'était totalement nul
tu dois te souvenir qu'à ce moment-là nous étions
dans britney spears en mode instinct
donc il n'y avait rien qui ressemblait à
ça et c'est pourquoi la maison de disques était
comme [ __ ] de quoi tu
m'apportes ça
c'est '  t qu'est-ce que c'est, comment allons-nous
commercialiser cela, cela ne correspond pas à ce qui se
passe en ce moment
à la fin c'est tout tu sais
sur cette section de pont je vais lui
dire que je suis désolé les choses que j'ai
faites tu pourrais penser que tu es un
joueur mais tu es complètement perdu
c'était vraiment ce que c'est  à propos de vous savez euh
c'est moi qui raconte une histoire
et à la fin le gars dit hey
t  ce sont des conneries totales dont tu
parles je veux que je vais
m'excuser auprès de ma fille
tu sais je veux dire et elle ne va pas prendre
ces conneries que tu vends
et c'est l'histoire mais le truc
c'est que personne n'a vraiment écouté  enregistrer
jusqu'à la
fin c'était un tel club que tout le monde s'en est
séparé
tu sais je veux dire et tous les gars l'aiment
parce qu'il est comme hé ce n'était pas moi
ce n'était pas moi tu sais je veux dire et c'est
le truc de fou  à peu près c'était quand ce
disque était à son apogée
euh nous recevions un peu de
réaction de la part d'un groupe de défense des droits des femmes
à ce sujet et vous savez comment c'est une
chanson de triche et cette chanson est bla bla
bla bla bla
mais ensuite quand nous avons regardé  lors de la
vente,
vous savez et vous avez obtenu les données sur le disque,
c'était principalement des femmes qui
téléchargeaient ce disque,
ce sont les gens qui achetaient
principalement des femmes qui l'achetaient,
j'étais comme oh mon dieu
tu sais et donc tu vois le  deux choses
qui vous disent que soit les femmes  sont
juste de bien meilleurs joueurs que les hommes que
vous connaissez ou c'est juste un mythe vous
savez donc
c'est juste une chose mais c'est vraiment une
chanson anti-triche
juste une mélodie si contagieuse vous savez
c'est ce que j'ai vraiment aimé
j'ai toujours fait de la musique égoïstement  je fais de la
musique pour que
j'aime ça et si j'aime ça alors je suis bon
tu sais ce que je dis donc je n'ai jamais
vraiment prêté attention à quelqu'un d'autre ou à
ce que les gens disent ils écrivent toujours des choses
tu sais j'ai été un  un il a gagné
toute ma carrière tu sais et quelqu'un
m'a dit ce
tchad tu es le plus cohérent à
un que je sais
tu sais parce que je suis critiqué parce que
j'ai commencé à faire du dancehall mais je n'ai pas
fait de dancehall dans son  scène authentique j'ai
toujours fait une sorte de style hybride de
dancehall
et donc les puristes sauraient toujours que les puristes
du dancehall et du reggae
me critiqueraient toujours
vous savez mais je n'y prête aucune attention
mais j'ai juste continué à faire de la musique qui était
unique parce que je  je viens de me dire
bien ils critiquent  j'ai aussi identifié bob marley et j'ai
dit que
vous savez que sa musique était de la foutaise et
pourtant c'est devenu
euh le plan de ce que reagan a dansé
toute la musique reggae d'aujourd'hui
que cela a vraiment changé ma vie et cela
m'a amené à un courant dominant et
m'a amené dans tous ces  d'autres
plates-formes, donc même si j'avais mr bombastic
et oh carolina et ces disques qui
étaient gros,
ce n'était pas vraiment moi, c'était vraiment un disque qui
m'a amené à un nom familier à
l'échelle mondiale